merci jean pierre donc je vais prendre
maintenant la relève pour la seconde
table ronde
et comme on a pris beaucoup de retard et
que on aime être précis on va laisser
chacun s'installe et je vous demande de
le faire assez rapidement de façon à ce
que on puisse tout de suite attaqué le
deuxième sujet un oui à les installer
vous je voulais juste en trois minutes
un petit propos introductif pour cette
table ronde
ce que je sais qu'il faut gagner du
temps mais faut quand même prendre le
temps de faire les choses correctement
nous serons moins d'intervenants donc ça
prendra aussi un peu moins de temps donc
cette table ronde
d'abord moi je me réjouis qu'on puisse
la tenir et je veux faire un constat en
quatre points mais préalablement je
souhaitais remercier notre président de
l'organisation de ces assises de
l'agriculture et de la ruralité
nicolas sarkozy la vice-présidente
isabelle le callennec et puis notre
secrétaire général ainsi que tous ceux
qui interviennent sur ce sujet il ya un
petit peu d'agitation qu'on va demander
un petit peu de silence c'est vrai pour
moi un premier exercice donc je j'ai
besoin d'un peu de calme pour ne pas
faire les choses trop mal en tous les
cas on va s'employer défaire très bien
un constat en quatre points
l'agriculture l'agriculture les
décisions majeures sont prises à
bruxelles
et ça je crois que on oublie beaucoup
trop souvent
l'agriculture c'est tout d'abord la pac
et nos concitoyens sont trop peu
informés de cette situation
l'europe est gelée entendu plus ou moins
dans les propos de mes collègues
éleveurs tout à l'heure est plus souvent
un problème qu'une solution
et je crois qu'il faut faire de cette
perception un peu handicapante une force
est en tous les cas c'est moi en tant
que député européen le sens de mon
engagement aujourd'hui
et puis dans ce concert de 27 des 28
états membres
il faut effectivement que la france
reprenne la place qui était la sienne
et pour cela il faut que notre
agriculture retrouve de la compétitivité
et puis je crois que ça a été dit par
mon collègue de haute-loire tout à
l'heure il faut impérativement yannick
il faut impérativement que les
agriculteurs soient plus présents dans
les institutions européennes
les parlementaires je vous rappellerai
que notre famille politique
nous sommes aujourd'hui vingt
parlementaires sur 751 donc c'est vous
dire que il faut beaucoup d'activité et
beaucoup de ténacité pour arriver à en
faire entendre notre voix et le
parlement européen n'est rien si le
conseil n'est pas présent et or une des
grandes difficultés depuis quelques mois
maintenant voir quelques années c'est
que le gouvernement que l'on a à un
ministre de l'habitat de l'agriculture
qui est aux abonnés absents
moi je dois dire que depuis juillet 2014
que je siège au parlement
je ne vais pas croisé une seule fois
j'ai vu une fois harlem désir ministre
aux affaires européennes
petit déjeuner voilà et puis depuis
silence radio alors évidemment on
n'attend pas le ministre l'agriculture
pour travailler en tant que
parlementaire mais si on veut que les
décisions avec la place de la france est
que le rayonnement de la france soit
celui qui est durant de la performance
notre agriculture
il faut un ministre et un président de
la république qui soit aux manettes de
l'europe dans le couple franco allemand
qui fait qui est le moteur de l'europe
or malheureusement angela merkel et dans
le cockpit et le président de la
république est mécanicien à l'arrière
voilà excusez moi de le dire comme ça
mais c'est mon ressenti de
parlementaires européens et donc on va
tout de suite entamé cette table ronde
donc dominique chambrette même a déjà
rejoint et je lui demanderais pour lui
quelles sont les priorités pour marquer
le retour de la france
à bruxelles je demanderais aussi à louis
orenga de nous rejoindre
louis orenga le président de
l'interprofession des fruits et légumes
alors c'est ma famille d'origine donc
j'ai je suis bien accompagné et donc à
louis nous lui poserons la question de
comment aider les agriculteurs français
a bénéficié des politiques européennes
de promotion il a une grande expérience
que certes il est directement à procès
notion des fruits et légumes il a aussi
comme je le disais souvent s'accompagne
ici sévit dans le milieu de l'élevage au
moment d'une crise tristement célèbre
celle de la vache folle londres ap acial
bioulac qui est un peu loin dans la
salle de nous rejoindre et qui est
membre du copa cogeca dans la filière
cheval et je lui demanderais quelles
sont les conséquences concrètes du
manque de présence française dans les
institutions européennes
arnold d'alissac va nous rejoindre aussi
et nous aborderons avec lui les
négociations sur le tt ip ou le taffetas
enfin en tous les cas l'accord
transatlantique qui a pour objectif de
créer un grand marché européen américain
sur la question des normes et puis
jérôme agostini de la filière viticole
choix si on peut le dire comme ça c'est
un peu raccourci excusez moi et on lui
demandera de nous parler d'un d'un
modèle celui des interprofessions qui
aujourd'hui a été actée dans la dernière
pâques et avant de commencer cette table
ronde
moi je voudrais qu'on puisse dans notre
famille politique
réfléchir à la prochaine politique
agricole commune
la première elles datent des années 60
j'étais encore panne et ça m'a réjoui
elle a duré 30 ans puisque la réforme
suivante a été en 92 et donc trente ans
ça nous amène à 2023
22 plus exactement et donc nous sommes à
quelques encablures il ya eu une réforme
en 2013 qui est une
on va dire une réformette mais qui nous
pose quelques difficultés en tant
qu'agriculteur et je pense que si les
enjeux et l'agriculture on veut la
mettre là où elle doit être aujourd'hui
pour des tas de raisons qui ont été
évoqués dans la ta première table ronde
il faut que dès à présent on semaine où
travaillent dans notre famille politique
pour amorcer la prochaine politique qui
régira l'agriculture pour les prendre
trente prochaines années
donc jusqu'en 2050